two photon microscopy is one type of  fluorescence microscopy which is very  useful to image thick specimens two  photon microscope use  femtosecond pulse laser and this is  generally in infrared range we use two  subsequent pulses of photon which are 50  femtoseconds apart that means almost  coincident with each other to illuminate  the fluorophore the fluorophore relaxes  and emits fluorescence this is how this  is different from confocal microscopy  which uses one photon process two photon  microscopy is very useful because it use  a laser with higher wavelength higher  the wavelength lower is the energy that  means lower is the chances of photo  toxicity or bleaching two photon is very  useful to monitor behavior of animals in  real time and to image neuronal circuit  activity in real time that's how it is  very attractive to neuroscientist  subscribe for more